idea for roosie's idea must be to maybe
even give a night check
look at that uh magnus he brings his
rook down attacking the white pawn that
pawn is doomed
and look how he puts his rook because
he puts his rook far away from the black
king because he do
you do have to be very very careful
because he could have been tempted to
play another move
another rook move um i'm thinking of one
where there's potential to be forked
but uh okay and then there would be some
tactics in the air but i just like the
way that magnus
played and three seconds left on the
clock for foruja okay oh my god
has he he's just lost some time i think
he just lost on time or he resigned
it's not clear the youngster he had a
lost position but
um that is premature um to give up at
that stage
carson wins the game slightly shocking
end to that one
i actually don't think we've seen that
so far in the melt water champion's
chest or a player
losing on time that's what it looks like
yeah i think he did lose on time but his
position was so bad
but i mean he just couldn't find a move
i mean the problem is